como un reloj todos los días a las 4 de
la tarde david saca su piano en el cruce
fronterizo de médica en polonia su
música saluda a los refugiados a medida
que llegan
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es muy importante que yo esté aquí todos
los días es un gesto simbólico yo
necesito darles fuerzas y ayudar a todos
aquí tengo listas tres canciones
ucranianas que puedo tocar que aprendí
aquí en médica
quieres oír un poco
bueno
[Música]
david construyó el mismo su piano
portátil el músico alemán ha tocado en
la plaza maidán de ucrania y en la plaza
taksim de estambul así como frente al
bataclán tras los atentados de parís de
2015 él utiliza la música para promover
la paz una persona que no ha ocurrido
esa idea es persona que tiene corazón
porque la música es muy sentimental y yo
creo que es un gran apoyo para la gente
que deja sus casas
mientras la vida recoge nuevas canciones
en cada país al que visita tiene algunos
viejos clásicos a los que felizmente
regresa
[Música]